the eyes to the right 329 the nose to
the left
299 there it is the first time the House
of Commons has voted yes to a brexit
deal relief for the PM but this just the
first hurdle the nose to the left
322 fall in at the next just minutes
later the Commons rejected his breakneck
timetable to convert his brexit deal
into law but the deals not dead yet he
can have another go if he wants but he
won't get to set the pace I make this
offer to him tonight work with us work
with us all of us to agree a reasonable
timetable and I suspect this house will
vote to debate scrutinized and I hope
amend the detail of this bill a
glass-half-full the p.m. taste in his
qualified success
and you say in response mr. speaker how
welcome it is even joyful that for the
first time in this long saga this house
has actually accepted its
responsibilities together come together
and embraced a deal but he knows the
Commons has put the brakes on his
do-or-die Halloween / exit I must
express my disappointment that the house
has again voted for delay rather than a
timetable that would have guaranteed
that the UK would be in a position to
leave the EU on October the 31st with a
deal his fate and ours now in the hands
of the EU he's asked for the extension
will they grant it until we reach a
decision I would say we will pause this
legislation a lot has changed over the
past three years around here but despite
all the work brexit not yet done now
another pause the Prime Minister mr.
Johnson had come to the chamber earlier
in the day imploring MPs to back his
deal if we ratify this new deal we could
get brexit done and move our country on
that was the current here's the stick
well the public think of us if this
house again tonight votes not to get on
with it opening the path to No Deal in
nine days time but some Labour MPs don't
like his deal this isn't getting brexit
done it's continuing the agony for years
to come
while the DUP feel betrayed and left
behind there's not a chance to kick back
sovereignty in Northern Ireland even
those prepared to support the deal not
prepared to be rushed this is a hell of
a big document we cannot pretend that
two-and-a-half days is long enough to
scrutinize this is a huge moment three
years after that referendum and Boris
Johnson has managed what at times has
felt impossible
he's got MPs to in principle back a
brexit deal but this is brexit so of
course it's not simple they won't back
his terms or his timetable so they
haven't killed off the deal but they
have killed off that
Toba thirty-first bed light and now the
big question for the prime minister is
what does he do next does he go for a
short extension and try and pass that
bill through the Commons in November or
does he call the whole thing off and try
for a general election that of course is
not in his gift Parliament's box demean
Parliament can let him out what's more
certain is that for all the promises he
looks set to miss his do-or-die deadline
Beth Rigby Sky News Westminster